[Musique]
la sodomie
on n'a même pas le temps des comptables
des pots de musique tellement on a deux
choses aujourd'hui je vous le dis ça y
est elle accepte et je peux vous le dire
aujourd'hui je vais partir non la
semaine prochaine mais rien n'a rien
menouar margot robbie
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'adore me cacher des plantades
c'est ma vie c'est rien et pourquoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non
ah ouais quand même il savait qu'on à
l'antenne nous annoncer lundi on sent
bon
[Applaudissements]
l'émission le générique est plus long
que l'émission j'ai un conseil me suis
adonné arthur voilà qui me regardent ils
aiment bien maintenant je peux lui
donner des conseils
arrête les bombers ce faire je te dis la
vérité arrête parce que t'as pas le
corps pour encore encore et les colts
ont des corps il est penché très
ressources humaines des ves c'est ça
qu'il va bien toi parce que sinon ça
fait 1 comme à courbure comme ça on
dirait une perche pour un soin la choper
ohlala
[Applaudissements]
un truc rires je suis allé voir le 16e
de finale de coupe de france
atletico de marseille contre rennes
j'avais un avion juste après et ont joué
à côté de voilà à côté de istres et donc
il ya un mec qui me dit ouais t'inquiète
pas il ya un pote à moi qui va te
ramener j'arrive et là le mec déjà
j'arrive dans la voiture il lui dit
tiens je lui prêter ma voiture
le mec il arrive déjà il se met la
voiture et c'était une voiture avec
automatique avec les commandes au volant
et quand s'arrête le gars je suis à côté
lui je lui dis et frère tu es bien sûr
la conjoncture et comment faire ou parce
que il m'a dit déjà le mec je pars le
mec qui me dit t'inquiète pas tu as ton
abus a dit cela 20h40 il est 19h10 en a
pour dix minutes déjà j'arrive au mais
le jeu mais je vais pouvoir jeu mais je
souhaite moi 45 minutes oui on est bien
content et de marseille tu découpes
moyens tu sais quoi
basile laisse-moi conduisent tu vas me
dit voilà bon là on sort de la voiture
je prends la voiture
et voilà attaques commencent à courir et
là le mec on n'est pas ce qu'on est dans
un truc c'est vraiment on est dedans on
est paumé on est dans un truc vraiment
un peu paumé donc là il a le gars était
là là je suis il me dit alors j'ai dû
commencer à droite à gauche au rond
point tu prend 3-0 jeu tant que témoin
il faudra qu'elle abordait la personne
cela j'y mettais de la région doit pas
du tout
[Rires]
j'ai l'ado et juni est ce que moi je
suis bon voila j'ai lu mais pourquoi tu
me l'a pas dit avant ça il m'a dit je
t'ai dit quel bordel j'ai mis le gps
c'est quoi et voilà donc fait que
j'écoute et je me suis conduit moi même
à l'aéroport il dit c'était hier à 19h10
il est 18 heures 43
sachez que la personne n'est toujours
pas mathieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme d'habitude tu dis n'importe quoi
johnny hallyday son côté exhibitionniste
qui lui plaisait qui le flatte et et
flamboyante est magnifique et voilà elle
a envie de montrer son camp il ya aucun
problème très bien sûr c'est vrai je
sais la vie mais oui alors vous savez
qu'on à long terme salon
[Musique]